a um British mother it's now set to  marry a murderer in a U.S jail who she's  never met ah or you can meet people on  the outside no wait man they might be  criminals  I didn't even guess that what would you  guys do if that was like your sister huh  marrying my sister in jail what the [ __ ]  how did your brain go then you asked me  what would I so I'm Terrell right and my  sister how did everyone else take it  their initial understands are my  favorite the other day there was a  criminal and then he goes yeah look at  the picture and the criminal and the cop  or like holding him and Joe goes and  he's a cop  I always look forward to their first  line  and then you have to question yourself  right like did I explain that wrong yeah  yeah did I hook up you think you're  [ __ ] crazy so confident he's like  he's like I'm in prison